adrian peterson's quarterback in 2020
for most of the season was matthew
stafford i feel like
stafford has said more in the last two
weeks
than he had in his entire career
combined
seems like every day we got another
matthew stafford story matthew said this
matthew said that matthew said this now
he says
that he had a good relationship with
former lions coach
matt patricia he and i had a good
relationship no matter what anybody
wants to say i could go into his office
and talk to him that's a pretty low bar
he could get me on the phone whenever he
needed to i think we both grew in that
relationship i have a lot of respect for
him and who he is as a football coach
and an unbelievable mind that's a far
cry miles from
what stafford had to say and i'm pulling
up the quote here after they lost on
thanksgiving to the texans that was the
final nail
for for patricia stafford was asked
if patricia should remain the coach and
stafford said it's not my decision
that's for somebody else if you want to
ask me about the game
you ask me about the game that was the
kind of yikes moment for me that
that yeah stafford stafford doesn't care
stafford doesn't care if they change
coaches and stafford's not going to burn
any of his equity in detroit
speaking out for matt patricia yeah i
mean
at that point too you had to probably
figure
from a matt stafford standpoint i just
i'm
pretty much done with this and we know
that because right after the season
he goes to the ownership team president
and says hey guys can you trade me
please
and it turns out they say yes and now
he's going to los angeles and he's going
to be in la ram once that thing
becomes official at the start of the new
league year but i think
part of the issue here that he says with
matt patricia or the fact that there is
no issue i guess i should say
is that he's just trying to point to
okay yeah i could do all these things
and
you know we had a decent relationship
and we could get on the phone we can
talk and we could talk things out but
he's not really saying anything
about all the decisions that were made
and really when you look at it matt
patricia
is the reason why matt stafford is no
longer going to be a detroit lion
he basically drove him out of detroit
and there
was lose they took what jim caldwell had
you know nine and seven football team
and yes you could say what everyone
about jim caldwell and what he did there
but
they at least were a franchise that was
middling to
winning right now they're just the
losing franchise that they've been
and so i totally understand why matthew
stafford doesn't want to necessarily be
a part of that
but i also understand from the
standpoint of i don't necessarily want
to go out here and burn a lot of bridges
why he would say ah you know matt
patricia's not a he's not a bad coach we
had a good relationship but what does
that really really mean when you just
kind of look at the words it's kind of
empty
patricia's flaw was he showed up and he
tried to immediately instill the patriot
way into the lions
he he you know he he called guys out he
treated players the way that bill
belichick
treated players and it just didn't work
it didn't work he lost the players
quickly
matthew stafford i would guess never
stood up in the locker room let's listen
to him let's follow his ways he's
bringing in a bunch of super bowl
championships that it just didn't work
and and that's the problem with so many
of the bill belichick disciples even the
ones who say
i'm going to do it my way i'm going to
be my own person what they don't realize
miles is after 15 years with belichick
they have become him without realizing
it they think that that's
the normal way to lead a team showing up
and on the first day
when you meet with the team you single
out one of the stars and you
and you piss them off darius slay let's
make him the
the scapegoat let's make him the target
let's make him the guy
that i show to all the other players
there are no sacred cows here because
i'm going straight after him
doesn't work didn't work and and i look
at this quote from stafford he could get
me on the phone whenever he needed to
well you know what the texans can't do
that with deshaun watts and so i guess
that makes it a good relationship
it certainly makes it better than what
the texans have right now yeah i guess
you're right
but the thing about matt patricia too
and this always just struck me i guess
as a reporter
when he goes into that press conference
and then he says to the reporter hey man
you know why are you slouching you know
get yourself right a little bit you know
have a little pride in what you're doing
this dude
coaches with a pencil behind his ear and
you're talking about have a little pride
in what you're doing and don't look like
a slouch come on man
you got to be better than that well and
beyond the pencil and i think
going into his third season he finally
realized the connection between
or the disconnect between perception and
reality he'd let that beard just get so
crazy
and he looked like a far different guy
than who he was when you dealt with him
one-on-one i just think that
that 15 years with bill belichick will
screw up
anyone and it warps the reality
of what should be acceptable and
tolerated in a head coach and what works
and again
bill belichick can be whoever he wants
to be with all those rings
that that's the challenge when you're
one of his guys and you go somewhere
else if you don't win right away
you're not going to last because those
methods are going to piss off
everyone and they're going to start
clamoring for you
to be gone hi i'm mike tarico
and thanks for watching make sure to hit
subscribe for the latest news and
highlights
from nbc sports